Le destin de l'univers repose sur tes épaules.
Fais ce que tu veux, mais surtout...
N'appuie pas sur ce bouton.
Ça ferait immédiatement exploser la bombe et on mourrait tous
Allez vas-y répète ce que je viens de dire.
Je s'appelle Groot.
Noooon, ça c'est le bouton qui risque de tous nous tuer.
Recommence.
Je s'appelle Groot,
Je s'appelle Groot !
Oui...
Je s'appelle Groot.
Nooooooon !
À vous de jouer bandes de nazes !
Ouaiiiiiis !
Tu m'énerves sale vaisseau !
Bon qui a de la bande adhésive ? Je vais en coller sur le bouton de la mort.
Non on a pas de bandes adhésives.
C'est pas vrai, il y en a pas un qui a de la bande adhésive?!
T'as une bombe atomique dans ton sac, si quelqu'un peut avoir de la bande adhésive, c'est bien toi !
Il faut que je me tape tout le boulot !
Tu nous fais perdre beaucoup de temps !
Je s'appelle Grooooooooooooooooooooooooooot !
C'est très très mauvais signe.
Quand je touche quelqu'un je ressens tout ce qu'il ressent.
Toi tu ressens de l'amour.
Euh.. oui oui c’est vrai je ressens de l'amour désintéressé pour tout le monde ou presque...
Non ! Un amour sexuel...
Mais non pas du tout.
Pour elle !
Non !
[Rire] Elle vient de dire à tout le monde le plus secret de tous tes secrets !
Euh oui bon bah ça va ! Arrête d'en faire des caisses hein s'il te plaît.
Elle t'a mis la honte ma parole !
Allez a mon tour ! À moi , à moi !